-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-winning actress
you know from films
such as "Les Misèèrables,"
"Rachel Getting Married,"
and "The Devil Wears Prada."
She is currently starring
in "Locked Down,"
which is now streaming
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-3 million pounds, tax-free.
No consequences.
-One for me, one for you,
one for the NHS.
-You have thought about this
-You know, I need to
go meditate!
-Well, are you sure they won't
check it in New York?
-Shut up! I need to meditate
-What were you going to say?
-The man who bought
the diamond is bad.
He's really bad, and you and I
are good, and the NHS is good.
And good is better than bad.
And when I explained
all that to Grandma,
even she said,
"Well, yeah, that's true."
And she was a Calvinist,
straight as a rod!
Unlike me, who is weak
in the face of temptation.
-Live wild or die, Linda.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Anne Hathaway!
How are you, Annie?
-Hey! Hi, Seth!
It's so good to see you.
-It's great to see you as well
-Kind of.
[ Laughter ]
-As close as we can.
So, this is really
sort of incredible.
This is sort of the first movi
that documents the time
we were living in,
in early 2020.
This is when
the movie takes place.
All the characters are livin
through the pandemic
the way we all were.
It must have been
sort of thrilling
and interesting
to be doing that.
-Oh, it was exhilarating,
the whole thing.
You know, the --
'Cause I feel like some people
started smoking again
during lockdown.
Some people started
drinking with lunch.
And then we just,
like, took our feelings
and made a film about it.
And Steve Knight wrote thi
script that's so sharp and funny
and I found cathartic.
And it was just -- then I got to
act with Chiwetel Ejiofor,
and Doug Liman was directing
And all of it just felt like
we probably shouldn't do it,
but I'm so glad we did.
-Obviously a couple things
you guys were up against.
One, were, you know, the ver
intense protocols that we have
when we're shooting films now.
And this was shot in London.
But also you shot it
very quickly.
Is it safe to assume that
18 days is the shortest amount
of time you've ever worked o
a feature film?
-Certainly when there was
180 pages of dialogue to film.
There was -- I've never done
a 180-page script.
Normally they're about 120
and you have about four months
to shoot it.
This one was
a little bit different.
-I'm lucky enough to be
friends with Doug Liman,
who raves about you,
it should be noted.
-Aw.
-He is, I assume, the right kind
of director for this "seat o
your pants"-style filming.
-For this what kind of pants
Oh, seat of your pants!
I thought you said seed of
your pants, and I was like
"You know a very different sid
of Doug than I do."
-He wears some
pretty seedy pants.
-"He's got a huge heart."
I just --
There is -- I don't think
I would have said yes
to anyone else, but he has -
he's so inspiring,
and he takes these risks.
I mean, you know, he's about
to go into space with Tom Cruise
and make a movie
where he's shooting in space
And he just --
he has these ideas.
And when he hears someone sa
something's impossible,
he wants to show them
how it's not.
And I just love him to pieces.
-It's true that he's
going to space to shoot
a movie with Tom Cruise,
and for those who don't know
he shot "Bourne Identity" and --
-"Edge of Tomorrow."
And he's this
incredible filmmaker.
And yet, if you ever saw
the inside of his car,
which looks like a garbage can
you would think,
"I will not -- I will not pu
my life in this man's hands,
but he gets results.
He gets results."
-He's wonderful.
It was one of those things where
we were doing -- we all --
you know, it was such a really
hard year for everybody.
And it felt so incredible
to be a part of something
that not only just
employed people,
which felt like a really great
thing to be a part of,
but was able to turn all o
this rage and uncertainty
and all of these feelings
that we were all
just kind of fighting our wa
through and turn it
into something, like I said,
hopefully, cathartic.
And, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry, I get nervous
talking to you.
It's happening.
Is my neck red yet?
[ Laughter ]
-That's the intention.
We do try to keep people,
especially you.
We want to keep you
off your axis.
Hey, you know, you mostly shot
it in an apartment,
but you also --
and I think it's safe to assume,
you would never have been able
to shut down Harrods,
which is this famous departmen
store in London
that you guys got to shoot in,
which must have been
both exciting but incredibly
eerie to be in a place
that is usually so bustling with
human beings.
-It was that.
It was -- you know, it just --
it just kind of added to
the surreality of everything
But it sort of reminded me
of when I was a kid
and my parents used to
bring us to FAO Schwarz,
and we couldn't afford anythin
in FAO Schwarz.
My parents told us
it was a toy museum.
And that's what being in Harrods
at night was like.
It was kind of like the museum
of super fancy stuff.
-Yeah. That's -- Man, I ti
my cap to your parents.
That's genius.
-Very clever.
They had a lot of work-arounds
for stuff like that.
-There are some, maybe clich
is not the right word,
but things that I think all of
us have maybe at least thought
about doing
during this difficult year
that happened in the film.
So I want to ask you
if these are things
that you've ever done
in real life.
-Okay.
-And I will answer as well
-Scream into a pillow.
Yes or no, real life?
-So many times.
-Really?
-So many times. That actuall
wasn't in the movie.
We had done a couple takes
and then I turned to Doug,
and I said, "Can I --
I don't want to tell you
what I'm going to do,
but can I just try something?"
And he said, "Yeah,"
and I grabbed the pillow,
and I just screamed as hard,
like, loud and as hard
as I could into it,
and then I did this scene.
And at the end,
Doug's eyes were really wide
and he just went,
"Oh, do that again.
Yeah, that, do that again.
In the early days of lockdown,
I -- you know, we were all -
I mean, I'm still overwhelmed,
but especially in the beginnin
when, I mean, there was
just a lot to process.
I would need to release, but I
didn't want to scare my kids
so I screamed into
a pillow a lot.
-See, I think I just screa
too loud
when something minor happens
Like the other day, I got a very
small splinter on the banister
and screamed really loud,
and then my wife very calmly
explained to me that
it's upsetting to the kids
-I broke a bowl
that was very meaningful,
and I started to cry
way too hard.
And Adam had to come up to me,
and he's like,
"Honey, you are legit
frightening the children.
You got to pull it together,
honey."
-Have you ever stayed
in pajamas all day?
-Of course.
-Yeah.
I did do my best
to try to get dressed
just because I'm somebody,
if I don't kind of start my day,
get myself out of bed,
start my routine, I can get --
it can get a little mushy.
So I found it was good
for my mental health
to put on something
with a zipper.
-Yeah, I think that's right.
What about tie-dye?
Did you tie-dye any clothe
during the pandemic?
-I didn't.
But going back to Doug Liman
for a second,
you know, we -- like you said,
we shot this whole thing -
well, not by the seed of you
pants, the seat of our pants
But we didn't have a look fo
the final scene of the movie
where they'd been in lockdow
for a very long time.
And, like, with -- I think i
was something like 18 hour
before we had to
shoot the scene, I said,
"Oh, what about tie-dye?
Everybody was tie-dyeing
during this time.
Wouldn't it be funny if she'
wearing a tie-dyed shirt?"
And our poor costume designer,
who had done such an amazing job
and was so exhausted,
single-handedly dressing
everybody, just said,
"I just -- I just --
I'm very exhausted
and I don't think I can."
And Doug raised his hand.
He's like, "I'll do it!
I'll tie-dye a bunch of shirts."
So he spent his Sunday
tie-dyeing shirts,
came in with
a dozen of them and that's -
and I wore one of them
in the movie.
So I didn't. Doug did.
-He is a Jack-of-all-trades.
No one can say otherwise
about our friend Doug Liman.
-He can tie-dye.
He goes into space.
He does it all.
-[ Laughs ]
-Makes films in lockdown.
-Hey, it's always
such a delight to see you.
Congrats on the film.
And I really do hope next time
it's in person.
-Oh, that would be a dream -
that would be incredible.